welcome back to CBS mornings you are
looking at pictures of the Hazardous
conditions in West Reading Pennsylvania
as millions of Americans face some of
the worst air quality in the world like
what's happening right now in West
Reading there on your screen you see it
due to Canada's wildfires now this map
shows where the smoke has affected the
air which can make it much harder to
breathe you can see it's a massive area
yesterday New York City had its worst
air quality on record as Manhattan's
famous Skyline disappeared behind a
thick orange fog officials have advised
people to avoid going outside more than
necessary if you don't have to
especially if you're in these infected
areas Dr Celine gowner joins us now to
talk about possible health effects very
good to have you at the table you know
Celine I put on a mouse for the first
time in a while and I thought oh this is
so uncomfortable I felt like I was
suffocating but we really do need to be
more diligent wearing masks at this
particular time we do and I would
strongly advise against going outside
without a mask at this point we are
seeing in outdoor air quality at a level
that is dangerous for everybody still
not just people who are who have
underlying medical conditions or who are
very young or very old we're seeing this
being dangerous for everybody so what
are exactly the exact uh health risk if
you're exposed to this well for the
average person you might experience some
irritation to the eyes to the sinuses
headaches shortness of breath wheezing
coughing but if you're somebody who has
some underlying medical conditions this
could cause that to flare up whether
that's asthma COPD people who have
cardiac conditions this represents a
really tough stress to their heart and
lungs I saw some committed New York
smokers out yesterday taking that smoke
break you know they're going to do it
the law is I can't smoke it in there I'm
going to do it out on the street I like
that committed very dedicated
individuals yes um I am curious so you
know these are not the pollution we're
dealing with here is not from Factories
at the moment right there might be some
mixed in but it's primarily the smoke
the fact that it has a natural Source
like a big campfire essentially is that
a mitigating factor in any way yeah I
think there's this misconception that
because something is natural it's safer
I would not say that this is safe by any
means and just because it's natural
doesn't mean it's safe in addition just
because you can't see it doesn't mean
it's safe so to get to this kind of haze
that we're seeing on screen you have to
have very high concentrations of this
kind of air pollution in the air each of
these particles we call them PM 2.5
they're less than 2.5 micrometers in
diameter so less than a tenth the size
of a human hair those are tiny and so
those can get deep inside the lungs
cause inflammation and but that's also
why you need so much of it to be able to
see it okay so let's talk who's most
vulnerable I know I have parents in my
in their 70s I have a four month old at
home what should they be thinking about
right so very young very old people who
have heart and lung disease and also
pregnant women are the ones who are
going to be highest risk here and so
really be on the lookout for potential
symptoms again the heart and lung
symptoms because these are the groups
that are most likely to suffer
consequences if you have to go outside
because of your job your delivery person
you're a roofer somewhere I mean what
are there things you can do to protect
yourself well wear a mask and this is a
situation where those n95 masks those
really heavy duty masks we saw during
the pandemic would be really the best
mask there's also something called an
elastomeric respirator which is a
reusable one you can get those at your
hardware store or on Amazon those will
also protect you very well if you're
working outside limit the amount of time
outside take breaks
try to limit this renuous activity but
you know ideally people would not have
to be working outside in this what about
people inside yesterday it was reported
on Broadway Jody Comer stopped her
performance like six minutes in because
she said listen I'm having trouble here
and and understood steady had to come in
if you're inside I went home I said am I
smelling something does it smell
something should you do an air air
filter in your house is there something
you should be doing inside your home at
this time yeah so not everybody's homes
is going to be sealed as tight to the
outdoor air so certainly if you can
purchase one of those HEPA air
filtration units there's also something
called a corsi box c-o-r-s-i if you go
on YouTube you can figure you can find
out how to build those those are made
out of materials you can buy at any
hardware store a bit cheaper than
getting a HEPA air filtration unit but
if there's anything we should have
learned from the pandemic it's that air
really matters for your health so this
is something we should be paying a lot
more attention to yeah I probably should
it's not going to last that long I
probably shouldn't have broiled a bunch
of fish in the kitchen and smoked it up
yesterday no it doesn't open the door
Katie was dumb of me I apologize uh Dr
Celine down always great to have you at
the table